Horror is a genre that requires exact timing
and expert pacing in order to deliver the
maximum amount of scares.
While every horror fan has a well-curated
list of their favorite horror movies, there
are lots of incredible horror shorts you can
watch for free online.
Short, sweet, and terrifying, here are some
of the best spooky short films.
The Ten Steps
Children left alone by their parents is common
in horror, but it's effective for a reason
— parents usually represent safety.
The Ten Steps is a perfect example of a short,
atmospheric horror film with a grim punchline.
After the power goes out while Katie is babysitting
her younger brother, her father talks her
through it over the phone — but by the end
she ends up in a very different place than
she imagined.
Downstairs
One of the best horror shorts of the last
few years, Downstairs follows a security guard
investigating mysterious sounds in the basement.
The film sticks to the basics of horror movie
rules: an early warning of things to come,
some light character work to establish who's
going to meet the monsters, and then just
minute after minute of terror.
"Alright, that's f---ed up."
Symmetropia
There can something a little unsettling about
perfect symmetry.
Perhaps it's because things tend to be naturally
chaotic and we expect disorder, but for whatever
the reason, Symmetropia taps into something
very creepy.
For anyone who's ever been creeped out by
a Wes Anderson movie, Symmetropia leads you
to some very unusual places, and shows that
the strange fear of perfectly balanced things
might not be so irrational after all.
"Yo, banana boy!"
The Facts in the Case of Mister Hollow
One of the most inventive horror shorts in
recent memory, The Facts in the Case of Mister
Hollow continually plays on your expectations
and changes of perspective.
The film shows an old photograph depicting
what seems at first like a happy family vacation.
As the camera dances around the photo, details
leap out at the viewer, and the final shot
paints a very different picture than the opening
scene.
3 Versos
A strong production design can often carry
horror movies with weaker scripts, but 3 Versos
doesn't need the help.
The script is surprisingly dense, layering
a deeper mythology and some hidden surprises
into a naturalistic dialogue.
3 Versos is clearly indebted to classic black
and white horror films of the early 20th century,
but with a multitude of visual influences
that distort the viewer's perspective about
when the short takes place — adding to the
discomfort of watching it.
Alexia
Argentinian film Alexia acknowledges what
we've always known — that Facebook is evil
and trying to kill us.
Well, not quite.
The gradual build-up of guilt and subtle implications
of abuse in a relationship help take this
short to the next level, while the set design
and escalating discomfort keep it quite scary.
Don't Move
Before the opening title, Don't Move has already
gotten all of its backstory out of the way,
as six friends accidentally summon a demon
that's going to kill five of them, and let
one live.
The real treat of the short is the incredible
creature design and special effects.
Don't Move was supposedly created on a low
budget, but you'll be hard pressed to notice
as you watch it.
The Birch
It's not hard to see the similarities between
Don't Move and The Birch, as they share filmmakers.
Both shorts have an incredible creature design
and a stripped down story.
The Birch follows a bullied young boy given
a mysterious book and a promise from his grandmother
that someone will protect him.
Sometimes it's hard to see the forest for
the tree monsters, but let's just say, when
the tree monsters look this good, that's not
a bad thing.
This House Has People In It
A series of unexplained edits from home security
camera footage is the setup of the short film
This House Has People In It — which ends
up being a surrealist nightmare.
Part of Adult Swim's "Infomercials" segments
which air at 4 a.m., this short taps into
a deeply uncomfortable sense of voyeurism,
like watching a reality show from a horrific
alternate reality where every day is terrible.
Lights Out
With a very simple concept and execution,
Lights Out is about a woman who sees a frightening
figure that appears whenever the lights turn
off.
Like comedy, horror can depend on a punchline
that a viewer wasn't expecting, and this short
is the perfect example.
The Smiling Man
Most horror movies hide the monster from view
for as long as possible to keep the viewer
in suspense, but The Smiling Man gives you
an upsettingly long, direct look at the monster.
The short focuses on a little girl who follows
a trail of balloons into her kitchen where
a smiling man starts to play with her.
Which is obviously very very bad news.
Skypemare
In Skypemare, a routine Skype call between
friends goes horribly wrong when it looks
like someone is moving in the room behind
one of them.
Following in the storied tradition of technology
being a delivery system for horror, the film's
real villain is the short's most unexpected
twist.
On My Way
Hollywood loves the one-take tracking shot,
but we've never seen a tracking shot for a
horror short quite like the one in On My Way.
A man drives through town on his way to a
party, while something strange has happened
to the residents of the town.
If nothing else, hopefully watching the short
will encourage you to actually arrive at parties
when you say you will.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!